[Music]
n
all right you guys should be able to
hear
me I hope
so oh I'm sorry about that guys I don't
know what happened sometimes YouTube
like not YouTube but sometimes computers
don't work the way they supposed
to and it was like oh I know that you're
you're supposed to work this way but uh
we're not going to let you work this
way and uh that that's an example of uh
of
today as far as the other Lords joining
we'll
see we'll
see
yes you guys are H perfectly fine uh I
do want to make something transparent uh
this stream is sponsored we do have a
sponsor for this
stream uh so you know keep that in mind
that'll be later on not right now but
we're going to we're going to enjoy some
ha little
[Music]
first
oh the game
okay all right you guys it should
uh it should break it down a little
I'm still waking up a little bit guys
I'm not used to getting up this this
early I'm
struggling
but yes like I told you we will be doing
a
uh a sponsor thing here in a little
bit not necessarily right now
n I'm I'm
exhausted I'm I'm exhausted I couldn't
even tell you guys how tired I
am but when I was talking to
uh our
sponsorship you know I I asked them
could you know I do community day before
it that way uh you know cuz we ain't
been did a Community Day in a minute so
I figur uh that that would make the most
sense all right
um as you guys can see we're going to be
playing Halo 3
though I don't know
why we're going to be playing Halo
Halo 3 is what is what we playing
guys send me a
message send me a
message uh we are playing R Shadow
Legends here momentarily a little
bit but uh yeah if you you play
Halo come on come on
down if you play Halo come on down stop
being
shot and come on
down put me in coach you
in
now right now we're just going to fill
up a
squad and then we'll uh make our
own own games and
stuff but right now we just filling up a
[Music]
squad oh look at that we have like the
same thing but it's red versus
blue all right well I I got to know if
you want to play guys guys okay okay I
see you I see
[Music]
you thing for my brother okay I hear you
um
po post if what you
want hold
up I got to find you there we
go yeah okay
um we
might no you got I got to send you guys
the the
invites
oh it's not about here's the thing guys
I have so many people add me on like a
regular base that it's hard to keep up
like don't ever take it
offensively that you're not on my
friends list because there's a lot of
people not on my friends list half the
time I don't even want kid smooth on my
friends
list it is not anything personal I
promise you
that so if you guys want me to add
uh add me now
man all right so we're full
now
so I'mma go ahead and start
playing oh other people join
okay Zachary
join let's get some people from Lords
gaming.net
feel free if anyone wants to
join join up feel free to come on come
on do
through
[Music]
hello right there we
go wow that dude looks
crazy I look so basic compared to him
[Music]
I look so basic compared to
him oh yeah if they want to hear you I
got to turn on the setting I wish there
was a way to do this for a Phil what's
going
on um we're doing a a community stream
if you want to join cuz we're we're
playing Halo more than welcome
to I am streaming though yeah yes I can
hear oh my bad this whole time I've been
muted uh where're we're doing a
community stream you're welcome to join
if you want to uh I am streaming by the
way uh so you know don't don't confess
don't confess to any type of things that
you you know you don't want the whole
world to hear uh by the way there's no
report today yeah there's no cussing in
this in this uh the stream guys there's
no cussing in this
stream yes there is a show today it's
why I'm going at
10: and keep yourself muted kids uh it's
not too bad keep yourself muted Zachary
if you can't talk without
cussing oh it's weird live
Supremacy send me messages guys it's so
much easier if you send me messages cuz
I got so many people on my friends list
and some of them I don't have it it's so
much easier if you just send me
messages is the party live in the
chat huh is like everyone can hear us in
the party right yes so I want to point
out AJ's absolutely terrible with Halo
don't let him lie to you okay we'll see
we'll
see what kind of ping you guys get
probably
what yeah your latency lag um I don't
know I've never really I did have issues
with
uh some lag a little bit while
ago all right you guys see that
streamlabs you know that's our link to
uh uh to ra Shadow Legends man you I
definitely go and try that you I
actually been playing I've enjoying I
think I'm going to play that a little
bit more after the stream cuz uh you
know there's a clan feature too we're
going to have to go in there and show
the i all about it's hard
too all right I'mma
start I'mma start
again at issues
okay my son is also joining us say hi
by I guess we'll play
2v2 what you talking about you got is he
uh I mean
4v4
yeah
what do you guys want to play man I love
I I I love let's do husky raid husky
raid man you know you want to
ra no we're playing creative stuff get
in here Zachary okay send me an invite I
sent you an invite a few if you want to
get the first
sh yes there's a party
chat I'll totally send you guys party
chats you guys just send me messages man
I I sent a couple people party chats
they didn't they didn't invite so at
this point it's like if you if you want
in tell
me map that was a adct Arena going
coming along it's going good uh you know
I'm still I'm still working on it
good
good keep that
hustle are youall able to hear me I is
today guys calm
down we can hear
you
man people are Extra Man IOP is today it
is
today we good guys we good it is
today it's at 1:00 what's going on man
it's at
1:00 so I think I it's safe to assume
it's not 1 it's
10:30 there's a few hours between that
and where we're currently at now
[Music]
all right how many people we
got safe all right so we can do a
[Music]
3v3 how do I unmute my mic uh I don't
know are you you're I don't think you're
in in
this is he in the fire team I don't know
let me hold
up all
right all right we need all right I'm in
the fire team now yeah
uh we can switch over to the um we have
an uneven team chats we have an uneven
team I know a one of you in this chat
that wants to be
joining or we going to have an uneven
team I'll be on the uneven team it don't
matter to
me all right um I thought we supposed to
put the I thought we supposed to put the
good person like the best person on the
the team with less
players oh that's fine live
Supremacy
uh actually you know what everyone go
over there but me and my
brother there it's me and my brother
versus all of
you it's cool the logic is this just
it's it's fun logic okay uhu and he go
to Red U and heat go to Red now you wait
where's
the you going to tell me Zach you
scared I'm going to have crazy lag so
it's going to be like a
are y'all already in a custom game
no join the Fire team you're in the
party join the Fire team yeah I am in a
fire team
okay it say um is in a custom game yeah
I'm not in one yet okay
just all
[Music]
right
that is a left trigger uh God another
person NOP this
week h no I get it I get it I thought we
could make three
teams cuz one's
Observer hold up maybe I have to do
Lobby option it's been so long since I
play BL say he went
in okay okay boy come on in man we we we
love that you're coming to Xbox too by
the way come on in
now we got a full Arena
4v4 here here's my uh here's my gamertag
guys Jo join in and as my government's
up there too but at this point you guys
know what my name
is
all right there it is
guys what's up Jamaica
entertainment oh he's got to reinstall
the
game I thought Zachary can't you have
more
than one uh more than three team two
teams I have no clue man how do you not
know yeah I not really done too much
yeah do Customs very
often I think you can put it on a
free-for-all though where everyone's
kind of against each other I'd love to
see who wins that one yeah that sounds
like
fun I like my perfect amount of fun for
this game is free-for-all with everybody
and have super Fiesta you run into
people be like oh [__] or
sorry I'm used to saying some stuff like
that so my
fault but uh yeah if you can figure it
out I think he's a long time stop cust
games
really I don't know you might have to
figure it out
then all right all right so everyone go
to Red but me and Zachary and God you
come over uh to
me actually you know what I dictate this
stuff all
right
I don't got time to wait for you guys to
be
joining I got stuff I got to do today I
got sit here for 6 hours today I hope to
God it's not 6 hours I ain't going to
lie to you guys I hope to God it's not 6
hours stand in the super chats guys keep
them hostages I hope to God it's not six
hours so you know maybe um people still
uh coming off the holiday
Brokenness so
you might not have as many super chats
if you're lucky I hope to God they don't
do that today I owe you
chats Slayer all right Zachary don't let
me down don't let me
down we team playing team or free yes
it's it's three on four okay three on
four and I'm on the [__] I'm on the team
that has all right Zach I'm muting
everyone all right you ready yeah hold
up let me change this
before
dumper I can't risk uh I can't risk
Zachary losing his stuff so you guys are
just going to be able to hear
me
we got this
stuff oh in the bottom below
you look at that Zachary the first one
down yeah get out of
here
Co I'mma need
Zachary to pick up the pace
we've lost a teammate my community is
not trash at Halo
Zachary I'mma need you to pick up the
pace he's in the basement he's in the
basement he's got overshield on guys and
it didn't matter that's right
Zachary that's how we do
things get
[Music]
him don't go in the basement they're all
on there they'll jump
you they're outnumbering that's like six
to one okay really it's it's it's 4 to
three it's not like a huge out number
but you guys get what I'm
saying overshield
available and you fell off the map like
the jackass you
are a someone else fell off that was
funny
all right Zach we're going to have to
stick together you going to have to hold
my you're going to have to you going to
have to hold my
pocket
ofun Z what are you
doing what part is stick together did
you not C pring the sticker the together
Target spot
S7 sniper
available I'm going need Zachary to put
in that work
[Music]
wow the otaku really
otaku that wasn't yours or talku that
was mine I don't care what this thing
says
I think they're going for the
sword to
ite lost the
lead now you guys shouldn't be able to
communicate painful lesson
deployed
oh
oh everywhere I turn it you
otu everywhere I turn it
you someone's named YouTube channel says
add Zack is better than
you
yeah I just woke up too and it's not
preventing
me yeah we're not Hing any
that one one two
one another one
yeah I can't believe I did that I can't
believe I had that shot and I went to
melee melee just isn't the same
anymore power items
incoming okay okay
power it on the
field come on over come on
over come on
[Music]
over enemy halfway to Victory
man he had
me we got to actually start winning more
of these
engagements
5 minutes
remaining I got him though that's all
that mattered I got
him
and me trying to melee
man oh God I'm being shot
at yeah we got more room uh after this
match though
sheld it's two on one of
gun power items
available take me home
boys take me home
boys wow
there's a podcast Today George it's at 1
the podcast is always at 1 it's it's
it's it's not even
11 there's a couple people over
here I'm getting jumped at every corner
now
very disappointed in your performance
zip what's up what's
up
everybody stick in here on
me on
me we will not go without a
fight yes we stick
together let's get this
privacy overshield available we stick
together we are a squad this ain't no
lone
wolves mark them all you
want oh you got to got to be kidding me
me you guys got to be kidding me man how
you guys that close
together oh my God please don't say
that
minute remain we need two more
[Music]
fights
oh I hate you guys I hate you
[Music]
guys nah George I be joking one 1 p.m.
Eastern that that that's when I is I we
got hit up to do a sponsored stream so I
was like you know what let's let's play
play some Halo and then we'll do that
all right a
whereare okay we switching stuff up so
clearly Dawn is up there with
us uh
so okay so other people want to
join what's up chat what's up B Cloud
all right there's other people that
wanted to join join now is your
time now is your time to
join now is your
time
had all these people in there you know
they saw that attic skills you know we
don't want to we don't want to fight in
that I get it I get
it Zachary I'm very disappointed in you
though I'm very disappointed in
you
[Music]
I thought I thought zachie I thought he
had more in him
[Music]
man okay that's fine uh Lucius if you're
not in here uh I I could send you guys a
party
invite
what I don't know
all right so you are in here okay we
need one
person versatile
Reggie I don't know how to look
at Zachary shut
up send me uh uh or send me an invite or
a friend request
Quest
oh he's in
here all right send me a um a message
don't don't invite me send me a message
if I it kind of defeats the purpose if I
just join you guys because then I have
to reinvite all of them uh so if you
send me a
message send me a message it's easier if
you send me a message I don't know where
to look for friends
request like they got this thing all
weird I'm okay okay at it I'm better
than my brother that's all that
matters oh who do we lose
someone
I sent you the the the friend
request I got about 30 more minutes guys
and then I got to to jump on on the
other
thing see it's look at me right
now invite
party
heat killer okay heat killer is
here I okay God sent I think he accident
uh just hold
up I died 16 times it's go it's okay man
it doesn't matter if you
die yes we can hear
you oh hold let me try
to
all right see if you can join me
now just join off of the the
admin n it doesn't matter if you die
like don't don't come not come in here
because you feel like you're not going
to like contribute like this just is for
funds you know if King was in here you
know he probably would have a different
mindset on that but he's
not yeah king king's King's pretty down
to earth playing stuff people be acting
like we just going to flip out on people
that's that's not that's not what we
do
I don't know how to
recreate Vesta
Z we have too many people in
here all
right they renamed all the maps that I
would care
about looking for the one that used to
We call
guardan we just play on this one all
right we
start Toy Story map okay we'll play The
Toy Story map
you guys want to
play join in on
um join in on my
name
[Music]
Slayer neither of I someone suggested
it
oh they did such a good
job shoot
them
gotcha
b
b oh God he in a
bans yeah you should have stayed in that
was my
[Music]
friend oh might let me in before it
blows up
I don't remember even how to get in this
thing
Su oh
s
everybody
everybody there you guys go there we
go I hear a
ghost it's like you guys are
cockroaches he's over
here feel like that's
U look where I'm shooting
guys item
incoming items have
spawned I oh no it was it was someone
else I thought that was a t whole
time look at that man it's 13 to
three
I this is a this is a
massacre and that is perfectly
fine cuz I I I have no issues when I
when aaku jumped in that Hornet I'm just
saying I'm just
saying he got out of it cuz he probably
accidentally pressed the wrong button
I'm just
saying an exp at jumping out of the
Hornet I'm I'm just
saying an expert at bad
decisions oh he has guns in
that yo think caught me off
guard
woo
get up
there who's under the bed with
me
perforated go
go power items on
rofe is someone in the closet power
items oh I see
you someone's in the CL never
mind he was tired of yeah he was tired
of
me oh there you are you shoot was down
you
I knew the way he was strafing back and
forth that that was
a a talku got to tell if it's him or
not you know it's not helping you
win halfway to
Victory on the road
[Music]
again
oh use your
hands hands do it just as quick as
anything
else no mind I got a sponsored game I
have to play probably after this
game
oh oh
oh be on the hunt guys for these three
cockroach we exterminator is
Exterminating Andy's
room yeah yeah
yeah
power
in
yeah Power items
on yeah
yeah
I'd leave your team
too yeah
ah you were
saying I'm
God
yeah 5 minutes
remaining
confir
versatile I expect you to to carry us
the rest of the way man he's mean with
that
sniper man I'd be messing up man I need
to get better with I just get nervous
I've never been able to like break that
that nervous twitch when it comes to
playing person
of course I had to to
reload we need five kills guys we need
to kill them five
times get
him we need four
kills three three
[Music]
two
Victory
St that's how you do
things
nah it was perfectly balanced guys it
was perfectly
balanced it was a perfectly
balance we loved it it was
fun all right I got
uh we got time for one more game and
then I and then I got to start uh this
other
thing
now is the last
one man I got bad monitors I don't
really got like fancy
monitors the question is how extra is
King gonna be today on ILP
husky
raid
yeah get out of here with
that
flag they took ours go go get them
versatile go get get
him flag
return you know what to do
versus
no enemy flag
returned I blame
myself of course I fall off the
map flag
return escort escort they have our oh my
God where did the gravity hammer came
from the h Gods just not
looking
lost a
teammate okay okay let's do
this we
need flag
returned enemy captured your
flag oh he captured our
flag someone grab it pick it up they'
Tak our flag an ally took their
flag how'd he get one twoo
popping us
up flag
returned go go don't let them take
this a got to go through
me it's the nice kitty not the mean one
yeah get out of here get out of
here our team took the enemy get out of
here we ain't we ain't asking for
that man get out of here get out of here
get out of
here flag
return flag cap that's all that mattered
I just had to I had to distract you for
my peoples to get
there and I fell off the
map
oh Ally took their
flag
oh I can't get
him go after him Lucius get
him get
him
oh we going all the
way how'd he get a rocket with
me they about to score enemy flag
returned enemy captured your flag they
have our
flag we can't lose we can't lose
this we can't lose
this
eny FL flag
returned drop while
attack flag
return
get that get that get that get that do
it do it scar
scar
Victory look it always comes back to me
guys it always comes back to
me look at that
[Music]
all right I appreciate everyone for
coming through but we going to get to
our sponsored uh our sponsor stream guys
we we today we have been sponsored uh
yeah I talk to you guys
we have been sponsored by R Shadow
Legends shout out to them for sponsoring
uh this community
stream and uh we're we're going to get
on to it let me let me pop it up on the
screen here real
quick there we
go yeah I ain't gonna lie to you guys
this game it's kind of giving me some
issues this game's not like the easiest
thing in the
world all right so first off there's a
couple
things that uh that you guys need to
know
okay all right so everything's good on
this
end I PE you to yeah I won man okay so
first off shout out shout out to to you
know raid for for for sponsoring the
stream we're gonna play this till
probably about 12:30ish because I need a
little time for myself before the
podcast uh so you I hope you guys enjoy
it because I actually you know there's
some hard content on here you guys know
how I am when it comes to hard content
uh you know there are some stuff that I
want to go
over that I feel is very important first
off we got a clan guys we got a clan you
know I encourage you guys to join my
clan it's
called This is my clan guys this is my
clan go to
it
H one second guys I'm
sorry all right there we go so we we're
gonna play some of this now I had I did
play a good amount of it
yesterday uh the the game is kind of
like intense if I if I'm to be honest
with you guys you know when I was
sitting there the amount of characters
they have in this game is is crazy you
know one of those things where you know
I was playing especially these little
super
Ray you know you get a little a little
intense hold on let me find out is it
doing that thing
again let me make sure it pops
up so for some reason
okay okay we should be
good are we
good all right I think we're good for
some reason when it comes down to uh uh
OBS be having like this little glitch
that I always have to fix there is a lot
of different options in this game you
guys know how I am when it comes to you
know playing hard games uh I'm I'm a
huge advocate for it I like having you
know the option of playing like a
difficult game and and one thing I will
say about this game is is it definitely
has that man it it's it's not far far
between that you know there's a lot of
stuff that you can play when it comes to
this you know it's got dungeons campaign
it's got its own campaign what some uh
interesting you know cinematics you got
the Doom to what I like about this is
the the amount of ingame content that's
in this game it's it's crazy the amount
of in-game content that's in this game
uh so I think I think this is something
we're definitely goingon to look into uh
you know we'll play a little bit of the
of the campaign uh but you know I do
want to get look how much look how much
of this campaign I played last night
guys lower the game volume okay guys I
hear
you oh yeah yeah I see it
now all right that should be fun look
how much of this campaign I played
yesterday I kind of got obsessed a
little bit just a little bit but now now
I got to like grind and level up a
little bit because it's it's definitely
starting to get to the point where these
people they ain't playing guys they
ain't playing you guys know how I am
about turnbas games too I love
turn-based games uh as you can see in
the bottom left there is a QR code I
believe that's the way that you
uh you pronounce a QR code uh so I think
you know definitely go in there and
click it you know uh try it out man if
you guys like turn based games the
amount of variety they give you in this
game is is
insane and and not to mention how good
this game
looks you know they give you a lot of
options in terms of this it's on Android
all it's on mobile devices
too there's a a couple other stuff you
know we got promotions everything's in
the description
below
look at this
man youo what I like about this game is
just the amount of variety you can have
of characters I feel like there were um
I've always like games like that where
you can actually have a good variety of
games that you want to play you know uh
I think that choice is really big in
games I think choice is huge in games
and you can literally make these
characters play you know these teams
play as good as you want you know they
got over I think 800 characters that's
insane look look look at these people
man this dude's supposed to be a beast
and they just they they they they they
getting them man it don't matter though
I I think we fine we're going to
teleport we're going to revive him just
to be on the safe side and they just
take him right back down it's fine we
getting him we getting him up out of
there
though see look look how many Guardians
I have just from playing a little bit
you know you get a lot of Guardians just
for playing the the
campaign and one thing that we got to
really really look into man is is the
the character
development you know I actually feel the
character development is it's pretty in
intensive man it's pretty
intensive there's a lot of characters
that you could decide how you want to
play this
game the good thing too is if you play
this on PC they got the auto feature so
if you're doing something and you know
you you want to monitor something in the
background you just click this Auto
feature you know I was working on videos
yesterday and I was able to play this
pretty effectively because I can just
put this on auto now I don't do it on
auto every time cuz I feel like they're
designed to make the best choices not
necessarily the best choices you make in
every
scenario so you know sometimes you do
want to go to manual because it it gets
kind of kind of rough you don't go to
Manu I'm going to be real with you
guys look at that when he's got an
ability when he heals someone he makes
them invisible so it's easier to keep
like you know support characters alive I
should probably be utilizing his
abilities a little bit better
just a little bit you guys know how it
is all right so let's see
here we're going to keep going right now
it's not too too bad but this game man
the difficult spike is crazy like they
have these super raids we'll get to here
in a
second and and there very
intense like you know you guys know how
I am I like hard games and I I do
feel this qualifies man I like
turn-based games and hard hard games in
general you know games that give you a
challenge make you
think and I think that that is
definitely
here oh come on wall you got to try it
it's right there is the QR code man the
QR code is right
there don't don't don't come in don't
come in the chat with some extra stuff
unless you try it now if you try it and
you know it's not for you that's one
thing but you know come in here with the
unless you try it man that's all I ask
you know just try
it you know especially if you a turnbas
head you should have been playing this
already if you had turnbas said it's
like one of the few games that I know
that's like on mobile and stuff that has
a turnbas
features you were late and missed it oh
yeah this is the sponsor part of the
stream uh we would have more Community
streams guys we will you know I I know
we got to get better on that uh we just
be so
busy and I know that was kind of last
minute you know but shout out to raid
Shadow Legends cuz you know they they
gave me the opportunity to be able to
come out and play with you guys man you
know Wonderful
opportunity look how detailed the boat
looks that dude is so strong I like
these like AOE team attacks they're
pretty nice
daku man you you you you like these type
of
games anyone ever TR tried out Ray
Shadow Legends that's what I'm curious
have you guys ever tried this
game cuz it's a freeo playay game man
the QR code's right there you just go to
it use your phone open up the camera on
your
phone and try it out I think I'm going
to talk about this game on on the
podcast too I've actually really been
enjoying it I I I love turn
bit and I had to sit here and like build
a
spec I love when I actually have to like
choose how to play
strategies because I'm going to show you
guys here in a second how
real these these people
are
see these are these are the these are
the easy people well not necessarily
easy you want to go for people that's
going to be an issue this level
34 I could probably go without fighting
so I think he's going to be some form of
a mage we want to get rid of him now
played it years ago try it try it again
man
look like I said look in the description
a lot of little goodies for you
guys the good thing about you know ra
Shadow Legends they give you a lot of
you know options as a new player as
well man this dude this dude taking
damage
so let me explain you guys to how like
the the battle system works so here's
like the The Raid boss person well he's
not a raid boss but he's the boss of the
of the chapter so how it goes is like
it's
like it's like a rock paper scissors
method so you know you have I I believe
I I can't remember what the names are
but it's like blue is weak to Red Red's
weak to green and Green's weak to Blue
so it's like a rock paper scissors me
see these these two are green he's green
so we got one
blue and three green and on here you
know I got some I got some stuff man I
got red
green red and green so I probably should
build up a a a blue character and put a
blue character in here probably do that
momentarily after I I do this chapter I
think I'm GNA show you guys
show you guys what's going on with
um with these raids man like they're
they're hard like they they put that
part of my brain that's just like they
can't
win they can't win against
me raising attacks
let's get this support character out see
see he's
blue so I I'm pretty sure red takes out
blue no okay it it's not you got to
memorize that the way the rock paper
scissors work I'm sure when it comes
down to playing this on like a high high
level you really want to know
those so
green
the good thing is I don't really have to
worry about too
much all right let's see
here oh we doing
it oh Foul
Play
why is he not taking damage hold up
let's see let's see what that
is heill reduction oh he's blocking
damage for one
turn Okay so we're not we're not going
to fight him we're going to fight the
one that's not blocking his
damage all we got got
this
nah you're not going to be able to do it
on time I'm sorry guys I'm
sorry look at and some of these people
got like look at the character design
the
detail like this dude
is crazy looking
man
what I like about this is like the
faction differences like if you look at
barbarians like this she's part of the
Barbarian faction she's also an attack
unit and what what I like about them is
if you do cuz I was looking
yesterday let me finish this and then
I'll show you guys like the the options
it's it's really good part of this game
is like the amount of options that you
have if you want to play especially
since it's on you know mobiles and stuff
uh cuz this is like one of those you
know you sitting at a an in-law's house
and you don't really like the in-laws so
you can just sit here and play you know
R Shadow Legends you don't you don't got
to deal with
them you know if they say anything say
you
antisocial just play Ra Shadow Legends
that's what I would do I don't really
mess with my family a whole lot
anyway man that dude was strong
look they what the crazy part about this
is they will literally jump people they
will jump people on this
game the music on this game is pretty
hype too
okay what is that what's he doing over
there HP burn he's probably going to die
next turn so let's not worry about
him yeah I told
you see I got support characters cuz
that's how you play these games you run
support
characters it's like I said guys we we
got a clan man I's got a
clan G here and rough man oh I hate that
block revive
ability there's a bunch of
sold they're trying to take out my my
DPS let me go ahead and heal and get
that buff
up I think it's best to take this dude
out as fast as
possible
yeah they're going to they're going to
get rid of him pretty
fast put that shield on but now they're
not going to attack my my DPS they're
going to attack someone
else there we go got rid of
him I what does that move do again okay
just block damage in
general well we can't really do anything
so we might as a
hill oh she got that block uh you can't
get her up
anymore they blocked her
revive there we
go all right here's the
boss this should be
interesting so we got to take out her
minions
first
take out this person because I feel like
they cast magic to some
degree we ain't trying to hear
that hold on
guys
there we
go yeah great Shadow Legends
is it's a turnbas game man you know
Final Fantasy like but like lowkey you
know Final Fantasy
they that's the type of gam playay man
it it's it's it's good man I think you
know if if you want to get technical
there's a lot of aspects of this
game when it comes to like turn base
that you just don't see a lot especially
in in the in the mobile
Department you know people should enjoy
playing these type of turnbas
games I I feel I I generally feel if you
guys like turnbas games this is
something you'll like you know I I
played this
for a few hours
yesterday
these bosses are pretty pretty
nice we're going to get rid of her
though as bad elazar to they got their
narrative thing going oned from his
gown it bore Arcane writings and an
image of a horrifying ritual it was to
begin with the dark mass and it's like I
said guys bottom left that QR code
click that meanwhile Freed From The
Necromancer it's our link the surviving
of the all I ask is you guys try it it's
a free to play It's All Mobile I think
you guys will enjoy it man I really do
if you like turnbas games they know
reason you ain't playing this already
begged forgiveness for his orders
wrongdoings he swore to restore their
honor and to save the Bewitched folk
from commit their shards to
SRA
you guys forgive me I'm just checking my
email see if I got another
email all right so we took him out now
let
me let me guys show you some of the
crazy ingame content these people got
going on all right so let let's go into
the type of content that you got with r
Shadow Legends so you got the portal and
the portal pretty much means you could
you know you get these through the game
doing a variety of things like Quest and
essentially they help
you get
Heroes so as you can see you know they
got different variety different
Rarity RNG little RNG going on
so as you can see look at this
one
ooh we going for for
gold look at the character models in
this you got really get H my hat off to
them for the character models and what
what's crazy about this game too is they
got this
Fusion this Fusion thing going on this
Fusion feature where they'll have like
certain
Heroes Champions uh pretty sure they
call them
Champions so pretty much let's say I
keep you know getting the if I get these
people from the these shards okay and
what I like is they tell you where they
are too so you look at this you get
these people to where they're supposed
to and
level and you start fusing them so these
four make this dude and then these four
make this
dude and he's got some pretty crazy
abilities especially this
chick that's a crazy design that's a
really cool design looks like they they
got um Champion skins
eventually look how crazy this dude
looks
chat very
detailed all right so you know you got
that going on then you got the guardian
ring you know I've been I put him in
there so you know if you you know you
you you got to take a little
break your people working when you're
not even
there they're working when you're not
even
there you can put them in here and
they'll level them up while you're
gone I think that's a really you know
awesome thing to do then here's your
your factions we'll get to more factions
here in a
second then you got your
Forge which you know these are
interesting you can get a variet iety
things in the Forge if you got the
material to make these
chests Tavern is where you upgrade
people so for instance this
dude you know I can upgrade him but you
got to sacrifice other champions in
order to do
so so I'll sacrifice these
people he level
27 Oh I can that's interesting
see or you can give them these
things we're going to do
that level
30 we're going to do that
again level
33 oh appre appreciate it uh ninja
squirrel you know what we doing now is
we playing raid Shadow Legend shout out
to to raid for sponsoring the stream you
know sponsoring the community day uh
what we going to do is uh I'm going to
take you guys through some of the hard
content in this game because this this
game has some crazy hard
content got the Great
Hall you know there's a lot of things
you can do in this game they got
tournaments
all right now let's get to these super
raids all right so these are all super
raids they have a variety of difficult
spikes fighting these people and it gets
it gets pretty pretty hectic I I have to
admit that uh so for instance this dude
here will destroy me there'll be no
fighting no Pas go he'll absolutely
destroy me I'm A Little Bit Stronger
Than I was last time I fought him what
is this oh it's that um it's that dog oh
let's level that dog up a little bit
let's go to the tavern and level that
dog
up what does that dog do hold up let's
look oh oh that's right hold up we got
to level this dude
up oh I feel you you try it on on PC man
it's on PC
ninja it's on PC you know we got you
play it on
PC you know and if you look in in my
description there there there's some
stuff in there for you man there's some
stuff in there for
you we got some promo codes down there
you know they they they make it pretty
easy to to to jump in and try the game
out all right so let's let's try I doubt
I'll beat him but I'mma
try is this this dude dude
rough now look let me show you how crazy
this
m it's one of those things where uh you
going to want to
take see look how
quick you know I got a lot of
support see this is like you know one of
those things where it's like you want to
come here after you really
good yeah we'll try this Arcane Force I
like the design for
these Lady of talku the Halo infinite
custom mode looks insane it is man it's
fun it's fun but you know you know what
else is
insane this uh this rage Shadow Legends
man
I ain't going to lie to you guys I'm a
little I'm a little to the point
where the way that dude just handled
me I ain't
feeling did you see how quick he kill me
I ain't feeling
that I got to I got to level up and come
back with with a
Vengeance I ain't feeling that
who's the main character it's anyone you
want it to be
man it's anyone you want it to be you
know use that use that QR code down
there and you can make any of these
characters your main
character I will say this dude here
this dude here is
um is like my best
character look how insane he looks he's
part of the lizard men
too so what's funny is you know I like
the lizard men and stuff I was
looking so if you if you go
to faction Wars you'll see there's a
bunch of different stuff so you see this
Undead horde Crypt
now if you want to fight these people
you can only take Undead people
there that's in the faction as you can
see you
know it's
interesting it's interesting the amount
of content they put in this
game so I could put a little bit more in
here but these people would destroy me
you know this is like in-game content
stuff
who we going to
fight we're gonna fight this magic keep
he looks cool actually I've been
fighting this dude
here and I've gotten a stage seven let's
let's do
that see I'm A Little Bit Stronger Than
I was last time I fought this dude at
this level
you what I like about ra Shadow Legends
too is they go back and they focus on
the older content too cuz I'm sure when
they add these other raids on here they
what I appreciate what they've done is
they've went back and you know gave a
little bit of a difficulty spite to to
everything what are you
doing
all right let's attack the
all man he's taking forever to take
damage ooh I like that
dude I like him because he's like a
little bit of a support character
oh got
him what I'll probably do too is I'll
keep the the streamlabs thing up during
the podcast too where it tells you about
this because I want you guys I don't
want you guys missing out on the
opportunities so it'll it'll
occasionally be dropping that link in
the in the description
see if you guys enjoy
it it's like I said if you guys are in
turn base it's a fun game man and
there's not a lot of turn-based stuff
out there these days I
feel especially a
game that's constantly
updating ooh
see look at this dude ain't
playing let's get everyone
up
okay checking where that cat
was make sure you don't get himself
hurt see look look at this man the these
these things aren't
easy put a little buff up try to get a
little bit of Defense going on here hey
Kitty no you can't be up
here there we
go man look how strong this dude
is I don't know if I'll be able to beat
him chat I'm going to be real with
you
ooh
it's not looking
good he me as much as I possibly
can one turn I can get my other
teammates
up there we go
he's doing too much
damage so I said you make
your your
support oh I only got three
left
he's almost
dead yo I can't imagine like the amount
of damage that people that's been
putting years into this game I'm kind of
jealous of
them Hockey Star I don't know what that
even
is all right let's do this level 10 oh
level 40 I don't know about that chief
I think he would destroy me at level
40 why does he keep going on didn't I
just shouldn't that be
enough
um yeah
sure I doubt this fight will be too
complicated put it on auto for a second
talk to the chat see that's what I like
about this B
you know we sit here until they get to
the boss we can we can let the game play
so I like when turn based games give the
option to do
this cuz I was working on a video
yesterday and it was pretty easy to to
keep manage of everything cuz you know
they they let you offset the the battle
itself now like I said don't do that to
everything because some of these
people you can tell they're not designed
for the AI to fight them like that you
don't want that now if you're
overleveled you could probably do a
pretty decent job this is the first uh
iteration of this
character see what I like up here is you
could
see what their abilities are heals the
Champion by 20% of their Max HP at the
start of each
turn you know and you got to farm these
people too like I said they tell you
where all the the info
is hold up guys I'm doing something real
quick I appreciate you guys working with
me
here every we
go
see they ain't really much for a while
but once you start to get to those end
game ones they they get pretty
hectic it gets pretty
intense
I want to show you guys something before
I leave but here in the next like 30
minutes I got to start getting ready for
the
podcast oh yeah it's that ability I hate
that
ability I like too you you have just
click on
them you're eventually going to run out
of that
perk see watch he going to be a lot
stronger here
here
okay let's see
my headset went out for a
second another thing I like is they
allow me to do more than three
characters I feel like a lot of turnbas
games they you only have like three or
four you know there's not a lot that you
can have five so you could really you
know if all
the all the Champions they have
available to you you know put in some
work you could probably make some pretty
crazy
combinations what's up
Kevin
what's up Kevin how you
doing barely survive I hate to hear
that well we're gonna be starting the
podcast here
soon so you know
pretty good
there oh I always got him
man now she's level 16 she levels up
every time you beat her
it's like I said QR code at the bottom
left Kevin man people in the chat QR
code bottom left try the game out you
know in the description you'll see uh a
bunch of
promos you know in IOP we got our own
little clan in
here you know shout out to to to raave
man shout out to
raave because of uh you know
sponsorships and stuff it's easier to
to to do the podcast man you know we got
a lot of uh Ambitions this
year probably talk about that later I
don't know if C wants me to talk about
you know the goals that we have this
year they have a lot of debuffs
we going to load up on her you can tell
she's getting
stronger oh she healed
herself let's
buff
oh this this this is an
issue how much she heals herself every
turn
yeah we'll still win but this is going
to be a difficult fight later on I'm
sure there's abilities to help you fight
people that regenerate
health
we getting rid of them
all bunch of
Mages it's kind of crazy see how the AI
chooses the fight cuz most of the time
with the smaller characters I wouldn't
Focus too much
on on how I would choose to to heal I I
would probably be more
aggressive cuz I feel like you'll get
rid of them
faster
right there's the link too guys if you
guys want to play it
on on the website you know if you guys
want to play download it and play it on
on PC right there's a
link or you can scan the QR code play it
on your phone
tablet the divers of playing this game
is kind of crazy like all the places you
can play
it she's going to heal
herself see if you hold them uh if you
press on and hold it'll tell you what it
does so this weakens
them click info you can see weaken plus
25% of damage what's up dread poool
so this dude going to do a lot of
damage probably should heal
though tell
him oh she's not worrying about getting
health so then why should
I we going for the
trifecta
that don't matter finish
him oh he's starting to get everyone up
let's revive
everyone what's this do again attack all
enemies have place and weaken we like
weaken oh he's resisted
to
as much as I'd like to attack with him I
got to get that Health
up oh my God like the amount of damage
that's going on is just
crazy I told you this the endgame
content in this game is
intense this might get him down a
almost can I beat him oh I don't know if
I can beat her
again level seven might be I don't know
five
levels I don't know chat five
levels I think she'll beat me if we if
we push her again we're going to push
her again
though actually you know what we're
going to do
just to give us a fighting
chance what's up John
Wolf appreciate you guys throwing up man
you know I know when it comes to you
know sponsored streams some people don't
like them and I get it uh but you know
we generally like the games that uh you
know we work with we we like
them I'm a I'm a fan of gaming in
general to be honest with
you I can get down on just about any
game yes I want to level him up
completely
yeah we leveling him up
yes upgrade rank we don't need upgrade
rank Ascend you can Ascend Champions by
using potions to unlock new skills a
Champions Ascension level is indicated
by the number Stars a rank four Champion
can be ascended four times while a rank
three champion the typ oftion needed to
ascend a chion depends on they just got
[Music]
so so much see what I like
here yeah I appreciate it guys I
appreciate it what I like here is like
the amount of options the amount of
gameplay variety they give you and what
what I like too is like they're like
look you can go to the store or you can
go to the force keep and it's stuff they
drop in here
so you know if you if you want to grind
they give you the opp opportunity to
grind and I I really appreciate you
know I can see why people like this game
I really can cuz I feel like me and I
haven't really played it a whole whole
lot besides the few hours I played it
last
night but I could see the amount of
content that just in a way it could be
overwhelming and they have a really good
tutorial
too and like I said if you guys want to
try it out man the the there's a link
pinned try that man uh if you know you
don't want to click the link there's a
QR code right there play it on your
phone your
tablet I play it on PC though I'll
probably download it on my tablet I
ain't going to
lie something about making stuff a
little bit easier is pretty nice
probably download it on my tablet try it
out
there got
him all
right
ooh see what I like is I I it kind of
gives I like when when games tell me
where to get
stuff like I I don't like what when
games make me go off of their game to
find out how to find that particular
resource and this game's really good on
that they're like look if you if you
want to evolve these characters uh the
these are the events or you could go to
the store and buy them directly what is
this a lesser potion we we
need I don't remember which one it was
but it wasn't a
lesser okay let's see
here it was this dude want to send
him we need the big
one
yeah see it's either you
know you can always have the option to
buy but I love that there's an option to
grind
it we need the superior Force
potion so we have to get to to stage
eight before it's even
available let's try to get over
there we GNA do this
guys oh my
God what's up outlaw
what we doing now is we playing rage
Shadow Legends
guys there's a
clan you know guys need to to to to jump
on and you know pop in on the
clan you know let me show you guys the
the clan
stuff I showed you earlier but let me
show you again cuz I know some of you
are coming in here we're getting closer
to
IOP so I want to make sure that uh the
stream's over before then but if you
look at the clan as you can see Iron
Lord's podcast level one clan leader I'm
the clan leader
obviously you know it's going good man
it's going good you know definitely join
us I like how you know we can do
invitations where you search for
applications I can put an application in
here rankings tell you where everyone is
Clan quests we could come together and
do some Clan quests
Clan
shop Clan
League they really went above and beyond
with the clan features
man and here it's got its own quest line
I'm right
here have
F got a dragon in there don't really got
time to fight fight him go back to the
dungeons what I like about it is just
it's on mobile just the accessibility of
the
game
oo that's
nice
[Applause]
we going we going to
attack you can tell he's a lot stronger
than he
was yeah he's got this passion defense
increase defense to 1,500 no wonder he's
strong I bet you there's ability ities
in this game where you can bring their
defense down drastically or attack
without worrying about their
defense
oh oh oh you going down buddy you going
down
okay I don't know if we'll be able to
beat this
dude we're going to try
though level 40 is it's pretty
crazy we're going to try though I don't
know if it's possible we're going to
try you guys know I am the difficult
game conquer I can't let a game beat
me
oo Ally
protection we murking people man we
doing
it
ooh
oh my
God we all win this
guys oh my
God all right let's see if let's see if
the AI beats him this time he's getting
up there in level I mean we getting up
there in level
two okay so they they're ganging up on
it I like the AI in this game they it's
actually they actually think I I feel
like a lot of AI these days you know you
can't really do much with them but the
AI in this game is is pretty uh sound
now let's see if the AI can beat the
actual
boss he's
strong oh my gosh not we haven't even
took him halfways healthier I got a lot
of support characters so it's making it
a little bit harder for him to to defeat
me
ooh I think it's going to do it guys I
think the AI got
it you know I don't think we're doing
like serious damage to him but at the
same time I do feel like we are
uh we're getting somewhere
ooh yeah the AI got it AI in this game's
good man you know there are I will say
if they're like drastically stronger
than you definitely do a manually
but if you got faith in your in in your
characters I do feel like they they will
do
fine but he is starting to wear me out I
don't know I don't know if he could take
on the next
level we'll
see I think yep he's level
40 he's sign significantly stronger hold
before we even fight
him let's go to the
tavern let's rank some other people
up
okay try to get them up a little bit
at least
closer all right 25 is going to have to
be good
enough actually
let's let's give this dude that let's
give him
this
I don't know if we could do
it and see you guys see that man I I
played this so much yesterday they give
you weekly let me show you guys real
quick cuz we're have to get off here
soon I always end up playing these games
longer than uh I'm obligated to I told
you I guys I just enjoy games they give
you daily
sign in bonuses weekly
ones
monthly you know they they got its own
uh season
pass and what I like about their season
pass is they actually have a a good
amount of actual you know I don't like
when season passes don't have value to
it like they they got quite a bit of
stuff
they got some
challenges all
right let's do
this I don't know if we'll be able to
fight on level
40 but we going to
try so my people are doing pretty decent
already at the
gate I just don't know how we're going
to take on the raid
boss
ooh see my team is they they synergized
man all right here we go here we go
we're not going to do Auto for this I
don't trust the AI for this particular
fight we're going to aim for one person
okay so he increased his defense as you
could
see we ain't we going to attack this
dude all right so he's not doing a whole
lot to us right now but I feel like
three three people we we want to get it
down to just the
boss
ooh let's hit them
both we want that buff
too all right so it's it's mono and
mono we need to cast
weaken let's cast
ween oh he resisted it that's fine
oh this is going to be a really tough
battle what's up
back let's get him
up
ooh
they they
are I don't know
guys decreased attack let's get people
up as much as we
can yeah we we we want to get everyone's
defense up
too heill
reduction let's get more Buffs we need
all the Buffs we can
get oh
God I I feel like we could do this we
could do this
chat
all right let's hit him with
this ooh he hits like a
train
halfway I don't know if we're going to
be able to do it guys
heill up a little bit get a
debuff oh we got weaken on him
now we can do a little bit of
damage oh first person
done let's get her up we need her
damage
you have a great one too man uh podcast
will be starting here in about 45
minutes I'll probably go spend on this
about another
105 come on come
on oh it's not looking good
guys that's the last time I can revive
someone
just a little bit
more I think we got it we got
it that
was ain't no way we can do another 10 we
could probably beat him we could
probably beat them you know what let's
do
it I got faith in my
peoples and I got to be out of uh the
podcast starts here soon oh they're
level 50
too well he's level 50 they'll be level
40 there's another round he's on the
third
round h no it's not on Xbox uh it's on
your phone the PC you it's either on the
phone that you watching the stream on or
the PC you watching the stream I guess
you could be watching this on Xbox I
don't really watch YouTube on xbox but
uh the QR code on the bottom left alls
you to go to it uh there's also a link
that's on rotation in chat you can
definitely try it out there this is on
PC Android whatever you think of it's on
man uh I'm kind of curious if they'll
ever bring this on uh console I would
play this on
Xbox all right all right we we we
ain't they all level 50 we ain't winning
this
[Applause]
chat we ain't winning this this dude
about to about to oh my
god oh heal reduction oh that's that's
standy
oh
oh he does so much
damage we got to kill him we have no
chance of win oh my
God okay okay okay so let's just focus
on him we ain't winning this chat like
I'll be very surprised if we win
this
we need that
buff and we need this
health oh that looks like it's helping
us stay alive a little bit we got a lot
of Buffs right now but they're not going
to last
forever try to take as much as we
can uh we're about to lose all the
Buffs
oh just just focus
on we'll get him
up heal
everyone a little
bit just keep on the attack we got a
little bit of Defense going
on it's not going to matter though
guys if I can keep my main dude alive I
can revive everyone but he's got damage
he's got everyone damage he's ready to e
for
everyone he can hit
everybody
oh it doesn't take long for him to go
either that'll keep people alive for a
little
bit about
halfway
got a level 50 dude
guys oh my
God
[Music]
oh he'll kill me if I don't heal
myself it's not looking good chat it's
not looking good
if I had just a little bit
more Health the moment they take out my
main middle
do it's a
WRA we're going to keep going to the
wheels fall off
though he does gain some
health
yeah
oh try to heal me as much as
possible yeah let's get everyone up can
we do it chat can we do
it
oh oh the good thing is I can get him
back
up I'm getting nervous I'm
sweating
uh oh God guys it was so close he had
that much health I thought we was going
to pull through I really thought we was
going to pull
through
ah oh my God
all right so guys like I said man once
again shout out to raid Shadow Legends
uh you know you guys definitely came
through sponsoring uh the stream
sponsoring the community stream um in
the description you'll find all the
links that you need to it you know there
there is a QR code to the bottom left
definitely go there and try it out man I
enjoy it I enjoy
played this mad amounts of times last
night man I can't kept coming back to it
shout out to them uh you know it's like
I said that there's a bunch of promo
codes in the description as well uh join
our clan iron Lord's
podcast guys need to join them man we
need we need to take over raid Shadow
Legends our clan needs to be
magnificent all right look I'm getting a
checkin I'm going to be I'm my activity
gonna be
high but as you guys can see it's
12:30 I I did this 30 minutes longer
than I was originally init thought I was
going
to uh but that that's fine man you know
it's like when you having fun you having
fun but I appreciate we coming through
we're going to go and wrap this up once
again the QR codes on the bottom left
all the promo codes is in the
description below appreciate everyone
that tries it out you know definitely
helps out the show and we will see you
in 30 minutes
peace